>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Joan Weeks: [Foreign
language].
So, welcome to the Middle East--
African and Middle East
Division reading room.
On behalf of my colleagues
and in particular Dr. Mary-Jane
Deeb, chief of this division
who couldn't be with us today,
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Joan Weeks.
I'm head of the Near
East Section,
the sponsor of today's program.
We are very pleased to present
this program entitled Snapshots
of Ottoman Women and it's
in celebration of March
at the Library of Congress
which is Women's History Month.
So, we look forward
to featuring programs
that highlight special
events concerning women--
women's history.
But before we start
today's program
and introduce our speaker,
I'd like to give you
just a brief overview
of our division and
the resources.
And I've got an agenda today.
All of my Turkish-speaking and
reading people that have come
to this program today, I
want to invite you in here
to use these collections,
read the latest novels.
When you go to travel
to Turkey and you happen
to be going anywhere
near Bursa, wouldn't you
like to have this
wonderful book,
before you do, all about Bursa?
Look at all the fantastic
pictures.
Everything you would need to
know and look at about Bursa.
I'm going to set it
over here for people
to look at afterwards.
What if you're going to Izmir?
Well, here's everything
that you would
like to know statistically,
architecturally about
the buildings.
There is everything
about archeology,
how about romance novels?
Come on and read
the latest ones.
We've got newspaper,
microfilm those.
We've got all sorts of journals
and they're just waiting for you
to come in and use them.
And one of my favorite
new works is this,
all the wonderful artisans
in Istanbul, and there's all
of these poems in
Osmanli Turkcesi.
And then on the other side,
they're in modern Turkcesi.
And how nice you can--
I'm sort of very slow
at reading Ottoman Turkish.
So, what you can do is
look at the modern Turkish
and then figure it
out on the other side.
I love this side by side thing.
And I'd love to have you
come in and use these works,
and all you need to do
is search in our catalog.
You can get a reader
card on the first floor
and you can even request
the books ahead of time.
So, they're waiting for you
in our reading room
when you come in.
And I hope you'll do that.
Other things, we are
a custodial division
and we have three sections
that serve the countries
and collections for
researchers around the world.
We cover over 78 countries
and over two dozen languages.
So we're very concentrated.
The Africa section
includes all the countries
of Sub-Sahara Africa.
Hebraic Section covers
Hebraic worldwide.
And the Near East Section
covers all of the Arab countries
in Northern Africa, the
Middle East, Turkey and all
of Turkic Central Asia,
Afghanistan, even the Muslims
of Western China, Balkans.
So, it's very, very
extensive holdings.
And I'd also like to invite
you to try out our blog written
by our curators and specialists.
And I also would like to invite
you to like our Facebook page,
because then you're
going to learn
about all our future programs
and really get connected
to us in a great way.
Also today, I invite your
questions at the end,
but just be aware that
because we're webcasting this
for future broadcast,
you're kind of implicitly
giving your permission
to be videotaped in the program.
So without further ado,
I'd like to go ahead
and introduce our
speaker for today.
Betul Basaran received her
PhD in Near Eastern Languages
and Civilizations from the
University of Chicago in 2006.
And now, she's the associate
professor of Religious Studies
at St. Mary's College
in Maryland.
She is a historian of
the Islamic Middle East
and her primary area of
expertise, the social economic
and legal history of the Ottoman
Empire in the early modern era.
At St. Mary's College, she
teaches various courses
in the cross-disciplinary
areas of Asian studies, women,
gender and sexuality studies,
history and religious studies.
She uses an integrated
comprehensive approach
in her classes with an
emphasis on cultural--
cross-cultural encounters
between the Muslim world,
Europe and the Mediterranean.
She is the author of "Selim
III, Social Order and Policing
in Istanbul at the End
of the Eighteenth Century
between Crisis and Order"
and has published a number
of book chapters on the artisans
and populations of
Ottoman Istanbul.
She has also worked extensively
in the Ottoman Archives
and taught Ottoman language and
paleontology at the University
of Chicago and Georgetown
University.
Her latest project is on
urban space and mobility
with the focus on
the surveillance
of dangerous classes
of the Ottoman
and European cities,
very fascinating.
So without further ado, I'd
like to welcome Betul
Basaran to the podium.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Betul Basaran:
I'm really happy
and excited to be here today.
The Library of Congress
for historian
and a bookworm is a
fascinating place.
It's like a dream.
So, to be here talking to an
interested audience is amazing.
And I'm also thrilled to see
some old friends and new friends
who are interested in
what I have to say today.
So, I want to say a few
things about myself first in--
before I start talking
about our topic today.
So, I was born and
raised in Turkey
in a very, very secular family.
And anything associated with
the Ottoman Empire or the Sharia
or Islam, these were not
passwords in my household.
My family, I would say had
high expectations for me.
I was sent to a private
American school.
I did international
relations for my BA.
So, I was going to become this
great diplomat and bring peace
to the Middle East, solve the
crisis in the Middle East,
all of that, probably
working for a Western NGO
or the European Union or the
NATO or something like that.
So when I told them I was
going to go into a PhD
in Ottoman history, they were
not thrilled to say the least,
especially when I became
interested in the sort
of workings of Sharia law
and Muslim Women's agency,
things of that sort, it didn't
really make much sense to them.
And the reason I
bring that up today is
because I really feel
very strongly that because
of that modern Turkish
nationalist narrative,
the official narrative, plus the
orientalist European narrative,
those two things combined have
really had a pretty devastating
impact on our understanding of
the nuances and complexities
of both Islamic and
Ottoman history.
So, part of what I do in my
teaching and my research is try
to really question that
and ask the questions
that I really wasn't encouraged
to ask from a young age.
So, I remember going
to Istanbul for--
I grew up in Izmir on the
western coast of Turkey,
going to Istanbul for the
first time to visit some
of the Ottoman monuments,
this is back
when they didn't really have
good translations in science
and either in modern
Turkish or in English.
And I just couldn't read
any of the Ottoman script
on these amazing
buildings and monuments
and fountains and mosques.
I had no idea.
It was so bizarre.
It was like a schizophrenic
experience
to go see these places where a
hundred years ago people spoke
or wrote in a different
language and read
that stuff and knew what it was.
So as a teenager, I was
intrigued but it wasn't
until I went into
graduate school
that I really started
asking the questions,
especially about the way the
rhetoric about modernization
in Turkey and Turkey's
secularization
and modernization, the
way it's been presented
as a phenomenon that's
been welcomed by all people
of all classes and backgrounds
as if there were no
nuances or complexities.
So to ask the question--
questions about, well,
how did this impact
other people?
I know my family
really benefited
from these developments
and I had a great education
and I'm grateful for the legal
privileges and the equal rights
that I have under the law,
but how did this impact other
people, what are different ways
of thinking about this
history that happened in my 20s
which I think is kind of sad,
but better late than
never, I guess.
So, that's how I came into
the study of things Ottoman.
And so when I first read
the works of Fernand Braudel
on the Mediterranean,
I was really sad
to see him conceptualize the
Ottoman Empire as the antithesis
of everything European
and modern
or as really anti-Europe
is what he calls it,
and wanted to do some research
and gear my teaching toward how
to study Mediterranean societies
and the Ottoman Empire as one
and the-- or as partners
in this shared cultural
political environment.
So even though I would
argue, it's fair to say
that the Ottoman state,
Ottoman society was certainly
distinctive, I would argue that
it wasn't exceptional either
in its militarism, its
brutality, its religious fervor,
or its misogyny or
patriarchy, right?
So, there are ways in which
people in this geography
and especially women
since we're talking
about women shared a culture
of patriarchy regardless
of religious difference in all
of these Abrahamic traditions.
So, we have to think about
Ottoman women's experience
within that broader context
and I'm going to try to do
that as much as possible in
the rather short time period
that we have to the
best of my ability.
So, let's start with
the Ottoman Empire.
This is-- All right.
So, there are some of
you here who know a lot
about the Ottoman
Empire already.
So if this is repetitive,
I apologize.
So, this is a map that
shows the Ottoman Empire
around the beginning
of the 18th century
at its sort of fullest borders.
And as many of you know,
the Ottoman Empire ended
after World War I and the modern
Turkish Republic replaced it
or inherited that legacy,
but that legacy is built
on complete rejection
of everything Islamic
and everything Ottoman
until fairly recently.
So when we talk about Ottoman
subjects, we're talking
about all of these people
in this geography even
though my research focuses
on Istanbul more specifically.
We have to remember that
this was a multi-religious,
multi ethnic empire.
So, we're not just talking about
Muslim Ottomans, Muslim men
and women, but we're
talking about Christian,
Jewish and Muslim men and
women and we're talking
about free people and
enslaved people, right?
There were also slaves
in-- on this geography.
So, I'm going to try to-- really
my snapshots, this is an attempt
to give you snapshots of
some examples, certainly not
in any way all inclusive
or comprehensive.
So, who are the Ottoman women
I'm going to try to talk about.
As I said, I'm not going to
talk only about Muslim women.
This is a picture from the 19th
century and clearly stage one
from like a postcard, but
that shows a Jewish woman,
a Bulgarian woman
and a Muslim woman.
The reason I start with
this picture is to remind us
that the daily lives
and lifestyles of women
until the modern era didn't
really differ a great deal,
right, in this geography.
We tend to really create
these binaries between Muslims
and everyone else, but
it's certainly historically
is inaccurate.
Here is an Armenian peasant
woman from South Eastern Turkey.
And I like that she's
smoking a cigarette.
So, I had to-- I don't
know, she could do that.
Here is how a Fazil
Enderuni in the 18th century,
the person who illustrated
this manuscript,
represented an Istanbul lady
in the 18th century wearing
this special type of shoes.
So, that's one way, another way
to think about Ottoman women.
And here is a-- from
the same work,
a scene of women just
chilling at this--
in this garden at the
park and there are a lot
of different things
going on in this picture.
So, I'll leave you with this
for a while as I proceed.
But as-- like I said, I'm going
to give you some snapshots of--
from the shared world of
Muslim and dhimmi or zimmi
in Ottoman Turkish that is
non-Muslim protected peoples
of the book, Jewish
and Christian women
and then both free
and slave women
and their experiences
in the courts.
And since we're talking about
courts, it's important to start
with a few things
about the legal system
in the Ottoman Empire.
Obviously, the Ottomans
created an empire that was--
that had Islam as
its primary religion.
But as a multi-ethnic and
multi-religious empire,
they had multiple legal systems
functioning in the empire
that were to sort of
different purposes.
So, the part of the legal system
that apply to Muslim subjects
of the Empire came from-- or
was based on the dual systems
of the Sharia or Islamic--
collection of Islamic principles
and also what's known as the
Kanun, the sultanic secular laws
and law codes that
were passed based
on the authority of monarchs.
And these two sets of laws
guided the legal system
basically, but they were
meant to apply only in theory
to Muslim subjects
of the empire.
So, Christian and
Jewish subjects
of the empire were not
subjected to the same laws.
The Ottomans recognized these
groups as separate nations,
millet is the Turkish
word used for it
and they granted the
religious leaders
of these groups very detailed
and specific administrative
fiscal and legal powers.
So, they had authority to
adjudicate and hear cases
in their own courts to regulate
private and spiritual education,
welfare, hospitals,
burials, cemeteries, clergy,
their own clergy, maintenance
of their houses of worship,
collection of taxes,
but also family law,
so matters of inheritance,
marriage, divorce,
custody plus any kind of sales,
sale of property, guardianships,
dowries, things of that nature.
So for all of these matters,
Jewish and Christian subjects
of the Ottoman Empire
technically had
to go to their own courts.
And as you can imagine, the
clergy also wanted to keep it
that way because it was
within their authority
to oversee the proper
functioning of those systems.
So within that broader
picture, let's talk a little bit
about what kind of rights,
legal rights women had.
I'm going to talk about
the Sharia courts mainly,
Sharia and Kanun.
But since we're going to
talk-- well, I choose--
I chose to talk today
mainly about family law,
it's going to be mostly
Sharia principles rather
than secular law codes.
So, what kinds of
rights did women have?
I would say that
although gender inequality
and male dominance clearly
prevailed in Islamic family law
and its application in
the Ottoman context,
especially through man's right
to unilateral repudiation
of marriage known as
talaq which I'll talk
about a little bit
later, polygamy,
concubinage for example.
Despite these things, research
on Ottoman family law
clearly suggests especially
since the '70s, but more
so in the last two decades
that Christian, Jewish
and Muslim women all
used the Ottoman courts--
the Sharia courts to
their advantage especially
for economic transactions.
They bought and sold property.
They inherited and
passed on their wealth,
established endowments, borrowed
and lent money and [inaudible]
or partners in businesses.
So, this literature has
really restored the agency
of these women who had
previously appeared if at all
as with one scholar has called
passive orientalist caricatures
in the scholar literature.
So, there has been
great enthusiasm
in using these court records
to document women's agency.
And some scholars have
taken this to argue that--
to question the existence
of patriarchy
in the Ottoman Empire.
I wouldn't go as far as to
say that, but I would say
that it's important to
recognize that women had--
Muslim women had certainly
privileges that distinguish them
from their counterparts
in most early European--
early modern European
societies who liked many
of the same rights,
especially in two areas,
in property and marriage.
And this is because women had
full legal rights as individuals
which in certain fields were
indistinguishable from males.
So for example in the types
of property they could inherit
or in the management
of their property.
Some of you probably
already know
that there's a standard half
share of inheritance business
in inheritance law, but
they regularly inherit it
from both their own families
and in their marriages.
And their rights in managing
that property were
identical to male rights.
So even though the law
and its application
and its interpretation
clearly favored men over women,
nevertheless women could seek
justice in the courts based
on these legal rights
and seek justice.
So just for comparison,
if we compare this
to the Married Women's Property
Act, the various acts in 1870
in the United Kingdom
and then in the mid 1800s
in the United States, this is
just as a point of reference
to highlight the fact that
legally, Muslim women,
and in this case we're
talking about Ottoman women,
had these rights that were their
inalienable rights for many,
many centuries before
European women got them
in the 19th century.
So, this is from New York.
New York's Married Women's
Property Act became a model
for other states in that period.
So, I really want to clarify
that my point here is not
to compare one kind of
patriarchy over the other
or to think about
which one is better.
But rather, it is to highlight
the fact that patriarchy existed
and I'm interested in
how women used the courts
to contest this patriarchal
gender religious hierarchy
in the Ottoman Empire.
So, one scholar,
Deniz Kandiyoti,
has used the term
patriarchal bargain for this.
So, women were literally
bargaining with the patriarchy
to make it work for them, but
still working within the system.
All right.
So then in my snapshots today,
I decided to give you examples
from three broad areas.
One, some things
that I talk about,
the women's economic activism
or financial activities
in court briefly, then about
family law, mainly marriage--
mainly divorce and remarriage,
and also matters of public order
and the business
of expelling women
from certain neighborhoods, so
literally just small snapshots.
And I also want to
point out that
as in other early modern cities
at the-- in the 18th century,
poverty was rampant
in Ottoman Istanbul.
So some of the women that
we encounter in the courts,
we can assume that
they are middle class
or have some access
to the courts.
There was a very
highly developed culture
of going to the court.
Women knew about the courts.
And there is this famous
saying that, you know,
men couldn't stop women from
going to the court, going--
and going to the hammam,
basically to the
public bath, right?
So, it was a legitimate
thing to do to go to court.
Our understanding is that
court fees were not exorbitant.
They were affordable.
We also know that very--
upper middle class and elite
families didn't typically go
to courts.
So, they try to resolve
matters among themselves,
not to being shame
to the family.
So, it was a last
resort for them.
But the types of women who
regularly used the courts seem
to be sort of middle
class urban women
with some exemptions of course.
All right.
So when we look at women's
financial activities,
we see again from these
records the use of court records
that Ottoman women were quite
active in the urban economy
of Istanbul as borrowers of
money, as lenders of money,
as property owners,
buyers and sellers,
founders of endowments
[inaudible].
They were managers of businesses
and they were landladies.
Middle class women were
very active in setting
up these small charitable
family foundations
that typically statistically
most often included residential
units, fountains, hammams,
public baths and rental shops.
They-- And they usually set up
their family members, husbands,
but especially their children
and frequently their daughters
and their slaves,
female slaves as their--
as the beneficiaries of these
foundations, endowments,
and managers of the endowments.
And so, their wealth typically
came from two sources.
I-- As I mentioned a little
while ago, part of it came
from inheritance because
women had inheritance rights.
So, they inherit it from
their own family members.
And then another
source of wealth
for women was upon marriage,
the dowry that they receive,
that's part of their
marriage contract.
So, a lot of women who had
sizeable wealth and by that,
I don't mean necessarily
huge amounts of wealth,
but large enough to
invest in something,
took this money and
invested it in.
So even though their wealth
came through passive means,
if you will, so they weren't
going out and making money,
they received it through
inheritance in marriage,
they were active in
investing this money.
We also see that they--
in addition to the courts,
see these various
courts in Istanbul,
they also used the
Imperial Council
and they petitioned
directly to monarch for cases
that weren't resolved within
the usual court procedures.
And so, they took
their grievances
to the monarch directly in this
process of bargaining in order
to manipulate the
existing legal system
to make it work better for them.
But again, I want to sort
of qualify this by saying
that I would not take
this as far as to suggest
that this gave women complete
control of their lives.
So, this activism in this
agency is very important,
but we have to remember
the broader context.
So, I wouldn't go as far as
saying that this activism
in courts is a direct proof of
women's control of their lives.
It is a huge privilege compared
to other women around--
at the same time.
So, women who are aware of these
advantages made it their regular
business to go to the courts.
And the courts were different
than how we imagine the courts
today and that the qadi courts,
the Sharia courts of the
Ottoman Empire worked also
as a kind of public notary.
So any kind of business contract
you have, you would take it
to the magistrate or the judge,
the qadi to officiate, right,
like I could enter a contract
with the neighbor for a rental,
something or some
kind of arrangement.
Without the qadi's seal, that
wouldn't be an official paper.
So, there are all kinds of
things in these court records,
not just criminal court
records for example.
So, they can tell us about--
a lot about the types
of activities urban
women were involved in.
When we move on to family
law, especially marriage,
issues of marriage,
divorce and remarriage,
let's look at what kinds
of rights the Sharia
or Islamic principles-- and
the Ottomans follow the Hanafi
School of Law, for those of
you who are knowledgeable
of the different schools of
law in the Islamic context.
So, Hanafi Law and Ottoman
application of the law specified
that upon marriage contract,
the woman should receive a dowry
from her husband, which then
became an inalienable part
of her private property, legally
and technically untouchable
by any male relative including
her husband once she had reached
legal majority.
So sometimes, marriages were
arranged before women reached
puberty, and they had
the right to contest
that arranged marriage
once they reached puberty.
And there are many cases
in the court records
where we see women come to
court, their husbands have gone,
they're either missing
or they've gone--
they've joined a military
campaign or they've gone
on a business trip of some sort
but they've been
gone for a long time.
And so we see women
go to court in order
to request the maintenance that
they're due from their husbands.
There is actually
a daily maintenance
that every woman is
legally entitled to.
And if the husband fails to
pay that maintenance to her
or provide that to her-- for
her, she can go to the judge
and say this is not
happening and I need it.
And in the cases when the
husband is either unable
to financially pay or
is away and missing
or for whatever reason
he's unable to pay,
the courts grant the woman
the right to borrow that money
on behalf of her husband.
So she borrows money and her
husband is legally required
to pay it back.
All right, so we see
women do that a lot.
There are a lot of
records of those.
But also upon divorce or
abandonment, women are entitled
to what's referred to as a
delayed portion of the dower
of the marital gift, if
you will, that's hers.
And so we see women go to court
with their marriage
contracts asking the judge
for the differed portion of
their dower upon divorce.
So before I move on
to some examples,
I want to make a few
additional points.
So we see that in according
to Sharia principles,
consent to marriage
is legally required.
So the woman has the
right to contest it
if for some reason she's been--
either her marriage has been
arranged before she was legal --
of legal age, which is puberty.
Or for some reason she has
changed her mind and they were--
even though men had
easier access to divorce,
women had legitimate
reasons to ask for a divorce.
And we'll talk about a
few of those in a minute.
So how many of you have heard
of the unilateral divorce
in the Islamic law, talaq?
A few people.
So, in classical
Islamic Law, men--
Muslim men have the right to
unilaterally divorce their wives
without going to court
or providing the reason,
a legitimate reason for it.
Women don't have the same right.
They have to proof-- they
bear the burden of proof.
So they have to go
in court and prove
that they have a legitimate
reason to ask for a divorce.
So while a man can
say I divorce you,
and there's a famous
triple formula,
so if he says it three
times, that's a divorce
and he is not required to go
register it in the courts.
The only reason we know is
because women go to court
and say he divorced me and
I need him to pay me either
because of custody
issues or because
of supporting her
and the children.
So we only know through
women who go
to court to contest it, right.
So I'm interested-- I'm
more interested today
in telling you about,
you know, what happens
or under what circumstances
women could ask for a divorce
and how the courts handle that,
and again how women used the
courts to make the system work
to the best of their advantage,
under difficult circumstances,
obviously.
So, a Muslim woman's
opportunities
for seeking divorce
included first
and foremost the stipulations
in their marriage contract.
So any marriage that has been
recorded in the courts have
to include a marriage contract.
And oftentimes, women could
restrict the conditions
in their contract under which
the husband could pronounce the
unilateral divorce.
So there are some
marriage contracts
where the husband gives up
that right, for example,
and it's written
in the contract.
Or oftentimes there were
stipulations that said
if he is missing or if he
is gone for so many number
of years, then that's a
legitimate reason for a divorce.
So disappearance,
abandonment, lack of support.
So if a husband is not
sufficiently supporting his
family, his wife-- this
is really about the wife,
not the family as a whole,
children are not part
of this picture that I am
talking about currently.
Mental instability, so
madness is a specific category
and there is a broad
category of harm, right.
So if a woman could
prove in court
that her husband is mentally
or physically abusing her
or causing her harm, that's a
legitimate reason for a divorce.
Of course how would
you prove that?
That's the tricky part but
these are legal categories.
Blasphemy is another
valid ground
for annulling the marriage.
But a very common scenario in
the court records is a story
of missing husbands
and deserted wives.
Like, so what happens
to these women
when the husbands desert
them for various reasons?
So the courts were prepared
to deal with this issue.
Because when men disappeared,
most women were left
without any resources, right.
They might have a small--
the lucky ones might have
a small amount of money.
They might have invested in
something or collecting rent
of some sort or maybe
working in some capacity
but most women relied on
family resources for survival.
Among divorce cases, the most
common form of termination,
or a divorce that was
initiated by women,
is what's called
a woman's divorce
or a female-initiated divorce
that involved the
woman's voluntary--
the woman giving up her right to
the delayed portion of the dower
that is by law owed
to her, right.
So if she can't prove any other
legitimate reason for a divorce
and the husband is not
consenting, then she can give
up that chunk of
money that's owed her
for support after divorce.
So, in a way, she is buying
her husband's marital rights
from him in return
for the divorce.
So, again, scholars have
written quite a lot about this.
My colleague Matt
[inaudible] who's at University
of Maryland College Park here
has written about this type
of divorce and it's questionable
to what extent this type
of divorce was empowering
to women.
Because on the one hand,
it shows that the woman
could divorce her husband.
And once he gives up that right,
it's almost automatic divorce.
He doesn't have to deal with
anything, any of the messy parts
of the divorce after that.
But how many women could do
that, we can assume that women
who had the financial resources
to support themselves could do
that or had the networks, family
networks, or community networks.
But we can assume that
a lot of women stayed
in miserable marriages
because they couldn't do that.
So it's-- the consequences
are complex.
And when women did that,
they also automatically
lost the custody
of their children, right.
So there was a lot at stake.
On the one hand,
you have this right.
But on the other hand,
it was complicated.
So now let's look at
a couple of examples.
We passed this.
Oh, we're going the other way.
Here. So, in this court case
from Ankara, we have a woman
who goes to court
complaining that her--
the inhabitants
of her neighborhood are
preventing her from remarrying.
And her husband allegedly
passed away four years ago.
She's been told by
someone that he had died.
And she wants to remarry which
is a very common scenario.
It was pretty much on her
to-- for people to not marry,
you know, Ottoman society.
So everybody married and
remarried for the most part.
Very few people married
only once from the records
as far as we can tell.
So he-- she's asking for
the right to be divorced
so she can remarry in the
absence of her husband.
And the court grants her wish.
So she's divorced
from her husband
and she's free to remarry.
And the neighborhood
residents are told
to leave her alone, basically.
Now here is another case.
Let's take a moment
to read and see
if anybody can tell
me what is different
between these two cases.
They're very similar
but also different.
Yeah. So we have a
Christian woman here.
An Armenian.
So what is she doing
at the qadi court?
Why is she at the Sharia court?
Right? Well, she's
supposed to go
to her orthodox Christian
courts, they're there.
And the law is specifying
that she should go
to her own community.
But it's actually really
common to see non-Muslim women
in the Sharia courts, which
is intriguing and amazing.
This is why we love history
and this work is
like detective work.
So why would non-Muslim women
go to the Islamic courts, right.
So in this case, again, the
court decides in favor of her.
And this is sort of
based on the Sharia
and maybe some of the law codes.
But technically speaking,
there is this nice division
between different
religious communities, right.
In fact, going to the
Sharia courts were so common
that in Istanbul the patriarchs
in both the Greek
Orthodox Armenian
and Jewish communities
periodically petitioned the
Ottoman Palace and religious
dignitaries to stop it
from happening because
they want to have control
over their own communities so--
and they kept going
to the Sharia courts.
So, I mean some of the
reasons are obvious
because from what we know, and I
have to say, I haven't ever done
in the research in the courts--
court records of
those communities.
So this is from secondary
literature.
But Orthodox Christian law,
when a marriage was annulled,
the husband did not return to
his wife the premarital donation
or the drahoma, given
by the prospective bride's
family to the groom.
And Jewish women had to get
from their husbands a bill
of divorce, again, that only
the husband could issue.
But by comparison Muslim
women-- in the Islamic courts,
women had some options.
So there were more options
in the Islamic courts.
And so because of this, we
see that non-Muslim women went
to the courts to
register their marriages
so that they could go back
when something happened and ask
for a divorce in
the court as well.
So I really don't know about
the applicability of this
in other Islamic Sharia courts,
but I know it happened regularly
in the Ottoman Empire in places
like Damascus, in
Aleppo and Cairo.
This is not just in Istanbul.
But again, at this point, I
want to say that my goal is not
to make a statement about which
type of law was more impressive
or more patriarchal,
whether Jewish
or the Christian Law was more
repressive than Islamic Law.
But rather, my point is
that these women
shared a common culture,
a common patriarchal culture
which did not easily allow them
to divorce or remarry, right,
whatever religion they were.
But the Islamic courts gave
them some extra options.
All right, another
example of grounds
for divorce is impotence.
So the sexual incompetence
of the husband is
a legitimate ground
for a divorce in Sharia law.
Again, there is the issue of
in the absence of medical--
modern medicine, like how do
you prove that, what do you do,
or how long do you wait?
There are very clear
instructions
in Sharia principles that
talk about a woman finding
out on the first day or
night of their marriage
that the husband some kind
of hideous deforming disease
or is incapable of
having an erection,
or that something terribly
goes wrong on that first day.
So the woman has the right to go
to court immediately
to report that.
And there are records
of it in the courts.
But more broadly, we also
have evidence of, you know,
women going to court and
oftentimes the judge grants
like a waiting period.
Like he gives like a year or
something and says like work
on it, it's probably, I'm not
sure but there is a period.
And then within that period, if
the marriage is not consummated,
then the woman gets the divorce
because there was a
basic understanding
of the basic rights, basic
conditions or exigencies
of civic life, right, that
everybody was entitled to.
And these categories refer
to the servants of God
in Ottoman Sharia law and it
included non-Muslims, right.
So everybody is entitled
to life property progeny.
So, if you're not
consummating your marriage
and that's a violation
of your basic rights
and the judge grants
you a divorce.
So at this point, in fact the--
this image that I used in a
flyer is an interesting one.
So this is a woman in court
complaining about her husband.
And she has some perhaps family
members, perhaps neighbors,
we don't know and
complaining to the judge.
We-- Maybe she also wants a
divorce so she can remarry.
We don't have that information.
And-- But what's interesting
about this is the judge
is holding something
and I don't think
there are any minors
in the room so I can say it.
He's holding a dildo.
The Ottoman word is
[inaudible], right.
So she's holding
or he's holding--
So she has presented as
evidence to the judge.
As evidence of her
husband's impotence.
Or, this is-- again, this
is not in the court records.
This is a miniature painting
that represents the
goings about in the court.
But I would say, hypothesize,
it sort of represents
in a satirical manner, perhaps
male anxieties about women going
to court and asking
for a divorce
or perhaps humiliating
the husband.
I have never seen a court
record that actually talks
about the [inaudible] as--
So I don't know if the
artist was inspired
by an actual record or not.
But we know that
women went to court
to prove their husbands'
impotence
and asked for divorces.
All right, any questions so far?
Can I take questions a little
or shall we wait, Joan?
[Inaudible] OK.
So let me try to get through.
All right then we'll move on.
So the next thing I want to
talk about was conversion.
So non-Muslim women went through
the item in Sharia courts
to make use of these legal
privileges, but also many
of them converted
to Islam as a way
of gaining even more
privilege in this society.
As you're reading this,
Marc Baer in his study
of the 17th century writes
that between 1650 and 1700
in Istanbul, hundreds of free
mostly enslaved Christian
and Jewish women converted
to Islam and not necessarily
because of marriage, because
they wanted to marry a Muslim
but for complicated reasons.
So for non-Muslim
women converting
to Islam offered an escape from
what may be more unbearable
or more patriarchal depending
on the context situations
in their own communities.
And conversion also gave them
the custody of their children.
So if a non-Muslim woman
went to court and converted,
not only was she immediately
divorced from her husband
but she also immediately gained
the custody of her children
to raise them as Muslim children
which was otherwise complicated.
So there were certain privileges
to conversion obviously.
But again, what I
want to highlight,
I agree with my colleague
Marc Baer, that this was a way
for women to opt out of one
type of patriarchal system
into another one that in some
ways gave them more options
but nevertheless also sustained
and recreated this patriarchy
over and over again, right.
Because they're opting into a
system that in some ways better
in this context but did
not challenge the working
of the patriarchal system.
And then there were also
slave women who converted.
And I would say that in
a-- in an Islamic empire,
a multiethnic, multireligious
Islamic empire, slave--
non-Muslim slaves were
at the very bottom
of the hierarchy, right.
So a non-Muslim slave
woman had the most to gain
from conversion, right,
because of certain things.
So, one, when a non-Muslim
slave converted,
she could not any
longer be or he--
I'm talking mainly about
women, so I can say she--
she could not any
longer be owned
by a non-Muslim slave
owner, right.
So if I convert as a slave
to Islam and I have a Jewish
or a Christian owner, then
the authorities have the right
to come and take me from
his position to make sure
that I'm going to be
owned by a Muslim family.
So that would be-- And that
tended to be the kind of thing
that Muslim elites
like to do, right.
So to sort of bring into
your household a newly--
a new convert into a Muslim
household was almost understood
as a good act of
good faith, right.
So that gave women an
opportunity to go from maybe
of a commoner to an elite
Muslim household, right.
But of course also, the best
thing that could happen was
for a woman, a slave woman
who converted to Islam
to marry her master and
bear children for him.
When a slave woman had
children with free Muslim men,
her children were
born slate free.
They were now born into slavery.
And in many cases, the
owners could free the
woman immediately.
But if they did not do
that, when the owner died,
the slave automatically
became free, right,
without any contestation.
So-- And not only that, but
she became an equal heir
to his estate.
So not only did her children
inherit equal shares as children
from other marriages,
but she also inherited
as an equal wife
in that marriage.
So we see a lot of such
records in the courts,
former slaves going to court
to do paperwork for inheritance
and division of certain shares
of estates and so forth.
Yeah, so here is one account
that I wanted to put up here.
I'm going to go quickly
through this now.
Here's an account of
a record in the courts
for a woman being freed
after having children.
The last type of thing I want to
bring up is the issue of women--
another way that women
we're very vulnerable living
in neighborhoods, especially
women who lived on their own.
So this could be women who
were widowed or divorced
or for some other reason lived
alone which would be rare.
But Ottoman government
and society in the absence
of modern police institutions
until the 19th century
used community policing
like community watches to police
themselves as small communities.
So it was everybody
else's business to spy
on everybody else basically.
It was very functional in some
ways which, you can imagine,
it put women and people
who were marginalized
in a vulnerable position.
So my own research for
my own book research,
I work with some
of these records.
I was interested in
matters of public order
and disorder in neighborhoods.
And my research in
the court records show
that this was the most
common type of complaint
about public order in
neighborhoods, that is,
a group of residents
in the neighborhood get
together, they go to the qadi.
They're usually the imam
and religious leaders
of the neighborhood are
with them and they complain
about a group of women
or entire families.
And basically the language used
in the records is very sort
of standardized probably
not the language
that the petitioners
use themselves.
But they found-- they
claimed that people were unfit
to live among them because
of various criminal behavior
or bad morals.
They didn't mind
their own business.
They didn't live
a righteous life.
For women, the accusations
were usually
about being disruptive
or dishonest.
This is probably a cover
up for not being virtuous.
For improper dress,
being verbally abusive,
using offensive language,
receiving unidentified men
and women in their residences,
disregarding multiple warning,
so there was a warning system
but disregarding these warnings,
and making such deeds-- misdeeds
a habit, so habitual behavior.
And in all of these cases,
and here is one example,
the accused allegedly
disrupted peace and order
in the neighborhood
so the residents did not want
them in that neighborhood.
And I have to stress
here that many times
in these records women
also appear as petitioners.
So women we can say were also
the watchdogs of their sisters.
So it wasn't just men spying
on women or men trying
to get women expelled.
There were often a lot of
women in the groups as well.
And these groups were mixed.
A lot of Ottoman
neighborhoods were mixed.
So Muslim and non-Muslim races
would come together to ask
for the expulsion
of certain people.
I think I had a number
of examples
but this is again a scene.
It's entitled from the same
work as the "Brothel at Night"
but they could just as well be
curious neighbors questioning
the integrity of these women
who really, if they were
on their own, didn't
really have a lot
of ways socially acceptable
ways to defend themselves.
So in this picture, you can
see there are some Janissaries
who worked, were
usually like the police.
So the imam probably
receives a complaint
and he goes knocking
on the door.
But even in these
cases where allegedly
in this case Fatma
Hatun was caught
with them indecently, right.
This is really sort of
covered up language, right.
That could be a cover up for
an accusation for prostitution.
And it was really stunning
to see in the records
that the accusations
for prostitution directly
are almost nonexistent.
Instead, you see
these bad morals
and we don't want them here.
So the question of what
happens to these women comes up.
There is no way of tracing
them unless they come back
to court to ask for something.
So there are cases where--
I believe I have one here.
Yeah, so in this case--
In this one, they say
they leave immediately.
In this one, three
years has-- had past.
So a group of residents went
to court and got a warrant,
if you will, an order for
these women to be expelled
from the neighborhood.
And then three years
later, they go back
to court saying they're
still here.
We came to court three years
ago, you said they would go.
So there's-- my point here is
that until modern nation states,
the state itself had
very little power
over the implementation
of communal matters.
So in a way, as annoying
as a spy might have been,
local communities had a
lot of autonomy compared
to how our governments sort of
know everything about us today
and police us and control us.
Well, in terms of
implementation,
it was up to the community to
make sure that those people--
my time is up-- that
those people left, right.
So in most cases, we don't
know where people went,
where these women went.
There is some research that
shows that they just move--
went to the neighborhood,
one neighborhood down.
They didn't go very
far, they weren't exiled
or they weren't punished
for their behavior.
In fact, there's
research on prostitution
in the Ottoman Empire
both from the Arab lands
and in Turkish parts
of the Empire show
that increasingly they were
being banished in this way.
But the state wasn't even
outlawing prostitution based
on immorality, they just
wanted to get this people
out of the public's
sight, if you will, right.
So there's this Arabic term
they use, tathir, right,
to sort of cleanse the filth,
but make it invisible rather
than stopping the deed itself.
So women just went to
different neighborhoods.
They were traveling from
one place to another.
And we really don't know enough
to know the real
implications of that for women.
So I want to leave
on-- So, you know,
a good note for women's agency.
There were also a lot of women
like Serife Hatun in this case,
who challenged the courts.
You know, this-- she-- there was
a similar accusation about her
and people thought she had
strangers in her dwellings.
And then they came and
that was not the case.
So she went to court and said
these people have shamed me
publicly, so I want compensation
for that and she got it, right.
So she challenged it and got
monetary compensation for it.
And I want to end
with some images
of Ottoman women
later 20th century.
But as the Ottoman Empire
was transitioning, again,
my point really has been
that this was a shared world
for Muslim and non-Muslim
women under the Ottoman Empire.
The same women started founding,
starting women's organizations
in the 19th and 20th centuries.
So this group, that included
Muslim and non-Muslim women,
founded this association.
And you see there's a plane,
a propeller in the background.
They raised the money for
this plane and they bought it
and they flew it themselves.
They've been asking for
the permission to do it,
nobody wanted to give them
permission or train then.
So they raised the
money and did it anyway.
And they distributed
fliers over Istanbul
to publicize their
organization for women's rights.
They founded this one
of the famous journals,
women's journals, again
Muslim and non-Muslim women.
And I'm going to leave you with
this my Turkish suffragists,
right, who campaigned for
universal suffrage in Turkey.
And they got in 1930 the
rights for local elections
and then 1934 is when Turkish
women got universal suffrage.
That's fairly early
compared to the global trend.
So these Ottoman women
together achieved a lot things
and I would argue that
it's a mistake to see them
as separate entities and
communities in a binary way
that we tend to do today
when it comes to Muslims.
Thank you very much for your
patience I think now we can
take questions.
Thank you.
[Applause].
>> Thank you so much
for such an awesome--
>> A little over my
time but I hope it's OK.
>> I have about one
or two questions.
We are running a little short.
We like to reopen the reading
room to our researchers
but does somebody
have a question?
[ Inaudible ]
>> No, you represented yourself.
And women were sometimes
represented by male relatives
or you could hire somebody
like-- or you could designate,
not hire, designate but you
didn't have to spend thousands
of dollars to get an
attorney to represent you.
No, it was face to face, direct.
Yes, ma'am.
[ Inaudible ]
I'm afraid I'm going
to disappoint you
and say I'm not really sure.
I really-- I haven't
studied the Arab provinces
of the Ottoman Empire
well enough
to really give you an idea.
But I know that in nomadic--
among nomadic groups,
there was resistance to
settle down and being taxed
by the government because
there were different rules
about taxation if you
weren't moving around.
Maybe it was resistance to
being a French citizen rather
than being a part of the--
But are you saying
they were not part
of the Ottoman Jewish
Millets when they were--
before the French came?
[ Inaudible ]
Out of it, I understand.
Very interesting.
I'm sorry, I don't know either.
Can we take one more?
>> Just one more.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, it was binding.
[Inaudible] It does
so the Ottoman Law did not
require non-Muslims to go there.
Non-Muslims would go to
the Sharia court only
if they had a conflict with a
Muslim subject of the Empire
about money or business
or whatever.
And neighbors fought
a lot, so they went
to the court all the time.
But if a Muslim was not
involved, they didn't--
they have no obligation
to go to the Sharia court.
But when they did, they went
and turned around and told
to go to their own court.
So if they came on
their own initiative,
the court granted them the
same rights they granted
Muslim women.
[Inaudible] So what
the rejection was
from the patriarchs we need
to do something about this
because our people are going to
your courts instead of coming
to us and they were losing power
within their own communities.
Thank you very much.
[ Inaudible ]
Thank you.
[Applause] Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.